and explosion at a fuel Depot in
nagorno-karabark has killed at least 20
people and injured hundreds as people
seeking to flee to Armenia lined up for
petrol the blast happened on Monday
nearly 300 people have been injured
dozens are said to be critical the cause
of the blast is still unknown thousands
of ethnic Armenians are leaving the
region following a military operation by
Azerbaijan last week more than 13 500
refugees have crossed into Armenia
Yerevan says it's preparing to take in
tens of thousands more from naguna
karabakh in the Armenian Capital Prime
Minister Nicole paschenyan is facing
growing pressure to resign since
agreeing to a ceasefire deal thousands
of protesters say he didn't do enough to
protect ethnic Armenians in
nagorno-karabakh
well in a moment we'll hear from Bernard
Smith who is near a registration Center
for ethnic Armenians who are arriving in
Armenia but first let's go to Osama bin
javaid who was close to the naguna
karabakh and first of all can we begin
with the fire at this Fuel Depot do we
know at this stage if it was at all
deliberate and do we have any more
details
but what we know Tom is that people were
queuing up to get this fuel as you've
been seeing these thousands and
thousands of people were fleeing from
the Latin border crossing where we were
yesterday and we saw a steady stream of
people cars lined up for miles going
through the Border Crossing into Armenia
and they were fueling their cars as well
as people who were within uh Khan candy
or stepanakhat are buying getting fuel
for their generators as well so it is
not yet clear what caused the fire but
it was a fire at a point where hundreds
of people had gathered there and that is
why it has such a high casualty count
where at least 20 people are dead and
nearly 300 have been wounded hospitals
across this region have been put on high
alert uh where the azerbaijani health
Ministry is saying that all the
hospitals around the nagorno-karabakh
area are have been equipped to deal with
patients most of the patients are being
dealt with within the territory most of
them have not come out there is a
Medevac which is going taking place from
a Yerevan to take the critical from
stepanakert or Khan kindy this
helicopter will bring in much needed
supplies as well as hospitals have been
appealing that they're running out of
supplies because of such a high influx
of wounded and injured people so it is a
tragedy upon a tragedy where people who
were already leaving their homes and
everything behind them lining up for
fuel and then this happened and many of
them have been wounded and injured but
people who we spoke to yesterday say
these are the kind of risks that they're
willing to take and move on from
Azerbaijan despite all of these
assurances because they feel that it is
no longer going to be safe for them to
stay inside as we mentioned earlier
already more than 13 000 people have
fled they're more planning to it seems
like a mass Exodus at this point in time
can you just give us an idea of what it
is like there at the moment
well you have to look back at the
history of uh nearly three decades on
when the many ethnic Armenians came back
to the karabakh region when it was taken
from Azerbaijan then in the consequent
war in 2020 these Takens would take
areas were taken back by Azerbaijan the
Latin Corridor were subsequently closed
and there was no Supply route between
Armenia and this territory which was
held for three decades so people know of
the history of what has happened in the
past they know and they've heard these
assurances and Promises being multiple
times by the azerbaijani government that
civilians are not going to be prosecuted
people who lay down their arms the state
is not going to go after them but
because of such Affair of what has been
happening for three decades people are
choosing to leave they're leaving with
whatever they can they're living with
what in whatever they can we have seen
tractors leaving lorries buses cars even
cars which where the wheels weren't
working were being towed by other
vehicles so people are fearing the worst
because now they feel that ethnic
Armenian leaders who were in this region
have given up their fight their
disarming they are going to be
abolishing all state institutions and
according to the latest negotiations in
region they're going to be replacing all
their flags with azerbaijani flags as
well so these are scenes of desperate
Jasper think that the only uh the best
option for them brother is to move
towards an unfuture uncertain future in
Armenia rather than staying in
Azerbaijan uh something that they've
called home for decades okay thank you
so much Osama that is Osama Bin Java for
us close to the nagorno-karaba
well Bernard Smith is now a registration
Center for ethnic Armenians who are
arriving at the Village of corned zor
near Azerbaijan and these people are all
obviously heading into Armenia but do we
have any idea where they will actually
end up and what sort of support they
will have
hey
Tom from this registration people will
leave here you see that cars constantly
going past Laden with everything people
could carry with their families with
their goods from their homes heading
into Armenia to essentially start new
lives The Armenian government says it's
ready to welcome to take in 40 000
families that's pretty much everybody
left living in nagorno-karabakh it's
very unlikely that anybody you see here
today anybody leaving the corner
karabakh will ever go back and that's
despite the assurances of the azeri
president that they can stay as long as
they were willing to be as Airy citizens
and the reason they don't want to stay
is because they've essentially been
starved out over the last nine months by
the Azerbaijan government which is
blockade in nagorno-karabakh the last
month or so many people here are barely
eaten just eating crusts of bread and
Azerbaijan is a country according to
amnesty International's latest report
where freedom of expression is severely
restricted and there are
arrest arrests and politically motivated
prosecution so it's against that
background that the ethnic Armenians are
leaving and it's an historical event
really because for hundreds of years
ethnic Armenians have lived in what is
modern day Azerbaijan and now it seems
the last of them are leaving
and Bernard in regards to negotiations
what's the US government been saying
so the usaid chief is due here at some
time today that's the head of the U.S a
U.S government's International agency
they want to keep an eye on how the
Armenians are being treated as they
leave uh Azerbaijan and ahead of that
the US government said that azerbaijan's
use of force is unacceptable and
Washington is looking for an appropriate
response and it's called on the azeri
president to live up to his promises to
protect ethnic Armenians now Ali have as
we've said he will guarantee safety but
at the same time he said that is his
Iron Fist that has consigned the idea of
the Region's Independence to history so
how much pressure the US government is
able to put on Azerbaijan now
azerbaijan's achieved many of his
objectives uh we'll have to wait and see
Tom
okay thank you so much Bernard we
appreciate that that is Bernard Smith
for us